the music is catchy it's upbeat and it's
urging young Russian men to join the
infamous Wagner mercenary group
there are also social media posts and
highly produced action movies portraying
Fighters as Heroes
Wagner has played a major role helping
Russia's depleted forces in Ukraine
but as its own losses Mount the group
needs more mercenaries to fight
it spent months recruiting from Russia's
prison system but stopped the practice
in February without giving a reason
with one source of recruitment gone
security analysts say online propaganda
has become more important
so here's how Wagner uses this content
to glorify the war and sell the idea of
Adventure and heroism to potential
recruits
the movie The Best In Hell was released
last October
the dramatic music special effects and
professional camera work make it look
like a Hollywood action movie but it's
actually a Russian production the one
and a half hour film showing a battle
between Russian mercenaries and an
unnamed enemy was produced by Wagner's
founder Evgeni pagosian he's a close
Ally of the Russian President Vladimir
Putin Security Experts say this and
other such movies create a heroic image
of the group which pagosian can use to
boost his position within Russia
also online are these music clips the
production is less polished but the
lyrics suggests that being a mercenary
for Wagner is more exciting than
everyday life in Russia
[Music]
there are even lyrics on screen for
viewers to sing along with
another video uses a female voice and
characters from Japanese anime to appeal
to young men The Wall Street Journal
wasn't able to determine the origins of
these clips
but the journal established that they've
been posted on Wagner Link's social
media accounts and pro Kremlin online
communities in September around the time
Wagner Watchers say the group expanded
its recruitment efforts
analysts say these in other similar
videos on social media make the war look
like a video game and trivialize
violence against ukrainians
some Security Experts say Wagner has
been desperate for new recruits
in January the US state department said
the group had up to 50 000 mercenaries
fighting in Ukraine many of them
prisoners but a Russian prisoner rights
organization estimated that about 40 000
either deserted or surrendered or were
injured or killed
recent Wagner videos give a glimpse into
the company's losses
here yovgini pregosian laid flowers at a
graveyard in Russia's South this was
another video showed pagosian and a
morgue surrounded by piles of black body
bags
pregosian didn't respond to our requests
for comment on Wagner's recruitment
efforts the Kremlin also didn't reply to
our request for comment on how the
company's recruitment efforts helped
Russia's military action in Ukraine
it's hard to gauge the effectiveness of
movies and music clips to promote Wagner
to potential recruits but analysts say
this type of content normalizes the war
as well as the idea that fighting for
Russia is just another career path
and it helps Moscow to continue its
recruitment effort as concern mounts
among many Russians over the possibility
of a second mobilization